مستمرون معكم مشاهدينا في تغطيهنا لاثار
الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا
وطبعا على الرغم من تضاؤل الفرص في العثور
على ناجين اخرين تحت الانقاض بعد دخول في
اليوم السادس اي هذا اليوم بعد الزلزال
والذي اودى بحياتي اكثر من 25 الف شخص في
احدى اسوا الكوارث التي تشهدها المنطقه
الا ان الامل يتجدد ولو قليلا مع تمكن فرق
الانقاذ في تركيا من اخراج طفلا من تحت
الركام بعد اكثر من 120 ساعه من الكارثه
منظمه دفاع المدنيه السوريه الخوذ البيضاء
اعلنت انتهاء عمليات البحث والانقاذ في
المناطق المنكوبه بالزلزال في شمال غرب
سوريا واعلنت البدء بعمليات انتشال الجثث
بعدما اصبحت فرص العثور على ناجي ناشبه
منعدمه المنظمه قالت ايضا ان حصيله
الضحايا حتى اعلان انتهاء عمليات البحث
والانقاذ بلغت اكثر من
حاله وفاه وقرابه 3000 مصاب في جميع
المناطق التي ضربها الزلزال شمال غرب
سوريا